hey what's up guys and welcome to a
series where we discover Dark Souls 2
one step at a time in this video I'm
going to try and show you 10 things that
you probably missed while you were
playing through the forest of the Fallen
Giants
it's also worth mentioning that this
includes new game+ I like to make these
videos into a sort of challenge with my
viewers I think that makes it a bit more
fun so how about this we'll play a game
with the like and the dislike system if
you learn something new then you leave a
like but if you know everything then
leave a dislike guilt free and decide
now if you feel like playing that game
and let's get into it the first thing
we'll talk about is this hidden wall
after you meet paté he'll tell you about
treasure inside this area behind the
gate but what he doesn't tell you is
that there's this borderline impossible
to find hidden door here and this door
looks like all the other walls this door
isn't even at a dead end it's before a
staircase and most importantly this door
requires you to press the interact
button before it did I mention that the
interact button doesn't even pop up no
okay
inside is a sorceress staff and an amber
herb which on the whole is not worth it
at all so I hope you weren't expecting
to get all the things in this video
because this is just the start the
second thing is another hidden wall and
most of you probably know about it it
has a bunch of explosive barrels around
it and you have to ignite them to open
it but did you know that you can blow it
up from the other side we have the
speedrunners on twitch.tv to thank for
this one because it saves you a lot of
time the third thing is what you get for
killing the pursuer the first time he
comes to fight you nothing you get
nothing just in case you were wondering
the next few relate to NPCs and armor
sets only available in new game+ for
example number four if he wanted the
hade knight's armor then new game+ is
the place to get it usually he only
drops his weapon upon death but in new
game+ he'll drop a different piece of
his armor with every new game number
five the same goes for another NPC
called Sven who waits outside the Kings
gate Sven was one of vendrick's proudest
Knights it was put to shame however and
his black phantom exists here in new
game+ just like all the other red
phantom
you'll have to start another new game to
get another shot at another piece of
armor number six is that there's a
Knight of Catarina in Dark Souls 2 and
just like in Dark Souls we can get the
onion Armour the Catarina Knight appears
at the third bonfire in the forest and
only appears in new game+ once again
he's up on this ledge and he'll drop
down to come and get you once he spots
you to farm the armor sets of all these
red phantoms you need bonfire ascetics
use them in the corresponding bonfire
and you'll be able to kill these enemies
over and over again because they won't
respond otherwise number seven is just
around the corner from the Catarina
night at the Fallen giant if you get
invaded anywhere in the world there is a
10% chance that he'll grow a seed of the
tree of giants on his arm you can't miss
it when it's there a seed of a tree of
giants makes enemies in your world aggro
on two invaders so you should check back
here after every invasion because it
makes it so much easier to deal with
invaders number eight if you exhaust
malicious dialogue she'll move back to
medulla where she'll eventually sell
infinite amounts of life gems it's
really useful number nine there's a
super easy way to farm human effigies at
the first bonfire in the forest of the
Giants when you burn bonfire ascetics
wooden chests respawn this chest up here
near the start of the level gives five
human effigies and it's a great place to
stock up and last but not least I wonder
how many of you decided to make the jump
down to the Salamanders I recommend two
things if you're going to try and do
this one try to take them out from above
the way possible especially this one
since it's guarding a chest and to get
the silver cat ring from shark WA and
you'll be able to drop down here with no
worries alternatively you can do a
plunging attack on this one if you're
feeling reckless down here you'll be
able to loot a fire Drake stone the hawk
ring a flame quartz ring plus one
cracked red eye orbs and the rebels
great shield and if you're insanely
lucky like I am you can also run past
everything and get the fire longsword
this way if you're looking to learn the
story behind the forest of the fallen
Giants then click here also let me know
if you learned something new let me know
how many you got out of ten and let
me know if there's anything big you
think that I missed click here to Kindle
the bonfire and I'll see you subscribers
in the next one bye